bonsoir Charles Philippe bonsoir Céline
alors reste une bonne nouvelle pour les
démocrates pour oublier que Joe byden a
quand même 80 ans moi je pense que c'est
une bonne nouvelle pour les démocrates
parce que je persiste des signes je
crois que Joe Biden est effectivement
celui qui peut encore peut-être on verra
battre dans mon Trump si Donald Trump et
le candidat républicain il a déjà fait
il l'a déjà fait et il peut refaire le
coup parce que je pense que tout autre
candidat ou candidate était vulnérable
face à Donald Trump ou face à un autre
candidat républicain est-ce que c'est
pas étonnant quand même qui est aucune
relève au Parti démocrate quand même
qu'il personne
qui s'est imposé oh monsieur Biden il y
aurait une relève mais je pense que ce
qui change tout et ce qui a fait que Joe
Biden a pris cette décision c'est
devrais-je dire la question certitude on
devrait pas dire ça mais en tout cas
probabilité que dans le tram soit le
candidat et publica et je pense que Joe
Biden et tout le monde sait que ça prend
un Joe Biden pour se mesurer un don dans
le Trump on ne voit pas d'autres
candidats qui devraient ou pourrait se
mesurer
au phénomène de Donald Trump qui détruit
à peu près tout sur son passage donc je
pense que Joe Biden FEDER tous les
candidats et les mouvements au sein du
parti démocrate et la raison pour
laquelle il l'annonce maintenant c'est
justement probablement pour couper court
toute possibilité ou velléité d'une
autre candidature du moins une
candidature on va dire pesante ou
sérieuse et aussi profiter de généreux
donateurs qui vont encore une fois
délier les cordons de la bourse pour
aider le Parti démocrate il y a déjà ce
vendredi dans deux jours une un
événement qui va servir à une telle une
telle un tel événement de donateurs
mais cela dit dans notre chambre lui
donne l'occasion parce que plus de gens
détestent dans leur chambre que ne
déteste Joe Biden donc parce que c'est
pas de candidats qui font l'unanimité du
tout au contraire beaucoup de démocrates
qui qui espérait que soit nos candidat
Biden mais encore plus de républicains
et d'indépendants qui espèrent
évidemment qu'il n'est pas à faire à
Donald Trump encore au cauchemar Trump
donc mobiliser l'électorats et surtout
dans cet électorat à les rejoindre les
indépendants ce sont les indépendants
qui à chaque campagne électorale aux
États-Unis on le sait maintenant font et
défend les candidats et assure la
victoire et ça c'est ces indépendants
des fois ils ont voté ils ont voté pour
Barack Obama ils ont voté pour Donald
Trump ils ont voté pour Joe Biden en
2024 Joe va vouloir les convaincre
encore une fois que ressort est en
meilleure main avec lui qu'avec son
adversaire républicain et donc il
réussit à convaincre ses indépendants là
en fait moi je pense que oui je pense
qu'il arrive il peut mobiliser cet
électoral sur des enjeux qu'on appelle
critique comme justement c'est tout cet
enjeu de l'avortement l'enjeu des armes
à feu aussi sur quel Biden a pris des
positions très très très clair voilà
deux enjeux pour lesquels là vous avez
une mobilisation de l'électorat de
banlieue ou d'Aix Birds comme on les
appelle aux États-Unis de banlieue
éloignés dans lesquels vous retrouvez
notamment beaucoup beaucoup d'électeurs
et d'électrices blancs qui changent de
camp comme je le dis d'une élection à
une autre donc ça va se jouer sur un fil
de rasoir encore une fois écoutez on a
une année et demi devant nous encore de
politique américaine est-ce que c'est
possible de dire encore plus
spectaculaire qu'on n'a jamais vu sous
et avec dans notre Trump je m'attends à
une campagne élect orale qui va être
haut en couleur avec toujours les procès
de Donald Trump qui continue on
recommande à Joe Biden de continuer de
manger ses épinards parce qu'on a besoin
de lui en santé pour pouvoir faire ce
marathon électoral jusqu'en novembre
2024 dans un an et demi merci beaucoup
Charles Philippe